okay so today I'm going to talk to you
about a topic in c1 called the evolution
of the atmosphere what this shows us is
how the atmosphere has changed over
millions of years so when the earth
first formed there were loads and loads
of volcanoes spewing lots and lots of
carbon dioxide and water vapor into the
atmosphere we can imagine this is
completely uninhabitable and yeah there
was absolutely no plants there was lots
and lots of co2 in the atmosphere and
lots and lots of water vapor now there
was water vapor because the earth was so
hot that water couldn't exist in liquid
form it was above above a hundred
degrees Celsius as a result it was a
water vapor kind of like clouds so over
millions of years the earth started to
cool down less co2 was being given out
by these volcanoes and as it cooled a
lot of this water vapor started to
condense so as the temperature drops
down a lot of what a lot of this water
vapor turned from a gas into a liquid
and started to come down as rain this is
how the oceans were formed so we can see
that we had a massive change in the
atmosphere this this cooling of the
earth caused the amount of water vapor
in the atmosphere to decrease
significantly also a lot of the co2
actually dissolved within the oceans so
at this stage here we actually had a
drop in co2 as well now over millions of
years we had a process of evolution of
something else going on simple plant
life started to evolve
in the oceans now these plants we should
know from from our other topics that
plants take in carbon dioxide during the
process of photosynthesis and they
actually release oxygen during the
process of photosynthesis so due to the
evolution of plants we had even more of
a decrease in the atmospheric carbon
dioxide and we also started to have an
increase in our atmospheric oxygen now
this was really really this is really
really good news because this
kick-started the evolution of other
organisms because before there was the
very little oxygen in the atmosphere due
to the rise in oxygen in the atmosphere
other organisms started to evolve
including including animals so the next
phase was due to a lot more of this
oxygen being available around the earth
there formed a layer that formed a layer
called the ozone layer now an ozone
molecule is an O 3 molecule and because
we had much more of this oxygen we
formed the layer all the way around the
earth ok so this is my this is my
diagram of the earth don't worry about
the the countries and the continents ok
so we could see this layer form all the
way around yes now how this was really
really helpful is let's say we have the
Sun right there this ozone layer help
really help to block harmful rays from
the Sun reaching the earth now this
allowed loads other organisms to be able
to evolve as well so we could see how it
changed over time
a quick recap at the beginning the earth
was so hot there was loads and loads of
volcanoes giving up lots of carbon
dioxide lots of water vapour over
millions of you
it started to cool all of that water
vapor condensed turn from a gas into a
liquid and form the oceans the planets
life evolved in the oceans plants during
the process of photosynthesis remove
carbon dioxide and give off oxygen the
oxygen helped to form this ozone layer
which is a kind of protective layer of
gases around the earth and these this
ozone layer helps to protect the earth
from harmful rays from the Sun thank you